I'm Jeff Dodds I'm a math content
creator here at Khan Academy I had a
fixed mindset for a really long time I
was convinced that I was a math person
and I was smart and I was just good at
math and so I remember the first time I
really struggled was I was taking a
linear algebra course and the homework
was not required it was optional and the
grade just came from quizzes every week
and a midterm and a final and I thought
that if the lecturers were making sense
then I must understand it and so I was
really frustrated with my initially low
scores I was and my brain started like
switching into this really fixed mindset
where I would blame the teacher because
they must not be preparing us well for
the quizzes but then I started to
suspect like oh gosh maybe I'm just not
that smart and maybe I'm not good at
math after all and I was just wrong all
along but um I took to like joining
study groups for students in the class
who were doing better than me and I
thought just by like being around them
that I could somehow like soak up their
smartness and like figure out that trick
that they had discovered and I was kind
of surprised that their their key to
success was just getting together and
doing the optional practice problems and
talking them out and people were
vulnerable and asking questions and
saying I don't understand this can
someone help me out with this and it was
the first time where I it kind of
clicked for me that Oh optional practice
like I don't have to do it just because
it's for grade I can do it to learn and
grow and I have to give up the idea that
I'm smart and I understand this on my
own and work with other people to ask
them questions when I was when I was
getting stuck with something or to help
someone when they needed it to help
myself grow and the grades would take
care of themselves from there I had to
give up that sense of oh I'm smart and I
can get this all on my own and it really
changed the way I approached my
coursework like not just in math but in
everything past that were I kind of
realized the importance of practice and
asking questions and being vulnerable
enough to say I don't understand this
and I need some help being able to admit
that to myself and to other people that
I do not understand this and you
understand a lot better than me so I
would like your help please that was
really big for me and that's still
important when I was a teacher or
my job today where I think you know
maybe there's a better way to teach this
concept and I can reach out to other
people and look at what they do it's
okay to not be the master because we're
all students we're all still growing and
everyone has room for improvement in
some way and that if everyone just kind
of quietly works on their own then
that's that's not going to produce the
best outcomes we can possibly get
because there's there's usually some
area we need help with and there's
someone out there who is happy to help
you so why not why not go take advantage
of that